in what ways can a screenwriter ruin a
scene it's almost easier to ask which
way they can fix it because there's so
many ways to ruin it I mean there's lots
of ways to do something badly you know
some of the most typical ways are just
you know exposition just using like
straight I'm going to explain exactly
what I want often if the dialogue
dialogue is if the dialogue is directly
proportionate to the desires like
somebody that walks around and says I
want this glass of water I want to shake
your hand I want you know they're when
their action is directly proportionate
to what they're saying it gets it tends
to get bad it tends to get you're not
you're not revealing anything about the
character and you're not exposing and
you're not emotionally engaging although
there was a really interesting exception
to that like did you see the killing of
a sacred deer no I wanted to I was
watching the trailer and and I think I
missed the window at the Laemmle and I
wanted to see it it's so I loved it I
mean excellent filmmaker but he did this
he did this thing where he's breaking
all the rules
there's no rules whatever it but um but
you know this assumption of like having
characters say exactly what they want
saying exactly what's on their mind and
delivering it in this kind of deadpan
way and it does it in such a way that's
incredibly intriguing and I still can't
wrap my brain around I'm still kind of
trying to understand why it was so
effective but I couldn't take my eyes
off of it like it's it's you know Colin
Farrell walking around with this kid
talking about watches and the importance
of just you know this this I think I
should get a new wristband and it's
important and there's they're very
matter-of-fact and it feels just left of
normal conversation like it doesn't it
feels very contrived and stilted and
it's for some reason you just slowly get
drawn into this kind of rhythm and
cadence and then before you know it
you're like oh these people are they're
not talking about their watches they're
talking about what these what their
relationships actually mean to each
other and it's it's so well done I loved
it morally I really want to see that
yeah that's really darkly funny like
there are a few movies this last year
that where they felt like these kind of
dark dramas but they were so funny they
were written in this great absurdist way
like mother
I thought mother was hilarious good to
see that looks really intriguing because
you couldn't really figure out from the
trailer what it was about it wasn't
really clear yeah I'm actually planning
on doing a video where I want to talk
about allegory and I think mothers much
more interesting than a lot of people
are giving it credit for it just because
of it's cool to see a filmmaker who's
deliberately engaging allegory and
allegorical tropes in a way the very few
are so it's and it will be fun I don't
that'd be forthcoming must be a tease
you